Tokio ist eine pulsierende Metropole und
mit 37 Millionen Einwohnern die größte
Stadt der Welt hier treffen Tradition
und Kultur auf modernste Technologie und
die Möglichkeiten erscheinen grenzenlos
aber eine Frage bleibt wie wohnt man
hier eigentlich um genau das
herauszufinden reise ich um die ganze
Welt um in allen verschiedenen Städten
zu gucken wie man günstig vs teuer wohnt
und wie schwer es ist an eine Wohnung zu
kommen und nachdem wir das letzte Mal in
Bangkok waren klären wir genau diese
Fragen heute in Tokio ja
ganz kurz bevor wir jetzt rein starten
in genau 7 Tagen Drop endlich die neue
Kollektion von tamek neue Shirts neues
Wetter neue sympolis neue Hosen und
Raphael behaltet das also im Hinterkopf
in genau 7 Tagen 30.04 12 Uhr Links zu
Instagram und im Webshop sind in der
Videobeschreibung vielen Dank für euren
Support und viel Spaß mit dem Video das
erste Apartment dass wir uns anschauen
liegt in absoluter Toplage nur acht
Gmunden von Shibuya crossing entfernt
und kostet rund 700 € Miete und was bzw
ob wir irgendwas für dieses Geld geboten
bekommen BMW jetzt starten mit der
ersten Wohnung ich muss euch jemanden
vorstellen Erik von ihaus Singen unser
Partner für Tokio für release date Japan
ist völlig normal dass die Schuhe
ausgezogen werden egal wo man hingeht
egal was man macht und deswegen tun wir
das hier auch bei der wohnungsbeginn
direkt beim Betreten der Wohnung ist mir
dieser komischerweise Kasten aufgefallen
the washing machine
of grace means washing machine goes in
here on the right
selbst in so einer günstigen Wohnung
gehört eine vollautomatisierte Toilette
zur absoluten Standardausstattung heißt
beheizter Sitz fünf und natürlich auch
eine Dusche die in der Wanne go back and
the walk down
you can see think and the bustomer
expert und tatsächlich ist es in Japan
meistens so dass das eigentliche Klo vom
Badezimmer getrennt ist selbst wenn wir
in dieser Wohnung unheimlich wenig Platz
ist reinfahren
living space
[Musik]
gut vorstellen dass man dass man hier
absolut happy sein kann natürlich zu
zweit es ist zu eng mit Kind wäre es zu
eng aber jetzt zum Studieren hier zu
sein oder als egal welche alleinstehende
Person in der Lage ist das eine hammer
Wohnung okay 700 € für eine 20
Quadratmeter Wohnung sind egal wo wir es
auf der Welt anschauen würden viel Geld
viel zu viel Geld der Blick auf das
durchschnittliche Einkommen eines
tokyoters gibt uns aber vielleicht noch
mal ein bisschen mehr Aufschluss ob es
sich wirklich lohnt dort zu leben oder
nicht und vor allem gibt es uns aber
Perspektive das übliche Gehalt liegt
netto bei ca 1,6 Millionen Yen das sind
umgerechnet 3.500 € pro Monat und geht
man nach der Faustregel ca 1/3 seines
Gehaltes für die Miete auszugeben liegt
man mit dieser Wohnung noch ziemlich gut
im Rahmen es wird sich bei Wohnung 2
aber gleich noch ändern das Interesse
für diese ganze wohnungsthematik
entstand bei mir durch die
projektwohnung die ich gekauft habe um
mich abzusichern und damit ich dieses
Gefühl mit auf Reisen transportieren
kann unterstützt mich nordvpn der
Partner des heutigen Video mit nordvpn
seid ihr nur einen Klick davon entfernt
euch vorher ganz zu schützen die
versuchen in öffentlichen Netzwerken
beispielsweise in Cafés oder Bars eure
Daten abzufangen danke fürs
bedrohungsschutzes seid ihr dabei zudem
auf allen Webseiten sicher vor
Schadsoftware Trackern und nerviger
werden gleichzeitig habt ihr weiterhin
Zugriff auf alle eure Lieblingsinhalte
auch wenn sie in dem Land in dem Ihr
gerade seid eigentlich gar nicht
verfügbar sind das beste daran ihr könnt
dabei sogar noch Geld machen indem ihr
einfach eure Location wechselt und dann
für den Preis von dort Stream und das
alles ohne Leistungsverlust schnellsten
VPNs der Welt checkt das ganze über den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
über
www.nordvpn.com/vpn ab und sichert euch
den exklusiv mit der 30 Tage Geld zurück
Garantie habt ihr genügend Zeit euch von
allen Vorteilen zu überzeugen und das
ganze risikofrei zu testen vielen Dank
an nordvpn fürs möglich machen dieses
Videos und euch viel Spaß weiter mit der
zweiten teuren Wohnung die nur 350 Meter
von der ersten Wohnung entfernt liegt
also genauso eine gute Toplage hat aber
unterschiedlicher nicht sein können
durch den Eingang an der Anmeldung
vorbei welche übrigens 24/7 besetzt ist
für Sicherheit sorgt und Dinge für einen
organisieren und annehmen kann bevor man
die Wohnung betritt rein ins Foyer oder
den Gemeinschaftsbereich hier findet man
eine Menge Sitzmöglichkeiten fast wie
eine Art Coworking Space und einige
Getränke und Snackautomaten außerdem
gibt es eine Gemeinschaftsterrasse und
allgemein muss ich sagen dass mir von
der Einrichtung super gefallen hat rein
in den Aufzug und ab in die zweite
Wohnung ja rein spaziert in die zweite
große und teure Wohnung
Apartment one family time
hinterm
and the pricine 30.000 5
[Musik]
eine Wohnung wie diese wird vor allem
von Mitarbeitern der dort ansässigen
firmengebietet das ist eine coole Lage
also sind dort Google und andere große
Tack Giganten mit natürlich gut
verdienenden Mitarbeitern dazu kommt
dass der Bahnhof figuras fußläufig zu
erreichen ist was einer der
hauptknotenpunkte in Tokyo ist und man
kommt von diesem Bahnhof quasi überall
ohne Umsteigen gehen das ist ein
absoluter plus das ist ein Menschen ist
new
leafated Action 19
[Musik]
das Konzept der Privatsphäre ist in
Japan von großer Bedeutung das sieht man
beispielsweise an der Benutzung von
Schiebetüren um Räume zu unterteilen
oder an den voneinander getrennten
Badezimmer und Toiletten hello
the walls and across second and
people like the hangster they have this
is that is a to the Badger
[Musik]
bevor wir ins zweite Schlafzimmer gehen
hat uns Eric noch eine Abstellkammer
gezeigt welche auch mit dem Eingang
verbunden ist grundsätzlich sind
Wohnkomplexe in Japan nicht unterkeller
weswegen innerhalb des Wohnraums super
viel Stauraum geschaffen werden muss und
das sieht man auch in den anderen Rollen
second legen
the discover
[Musik]
im Prinzip ist der gesamte Raum in dem
ich hier gerade stehe eine große Dusche
in der Stadt sieht man das ja ganz
häufig in den kleinen Wohnung das ist
auch in der Badewanne geduscht wird in
Europa hat meine Badewanne ohne Dusche
und hier ist es eben auch so aber alles
in einem Raum gefällt mir sehr gut so
was bedeutet
hier
zum Abschluss blieb dann aber noch eine
wichtige Frage wir sind easy together in
Apartment oriz it like you have plenty
of people wanting the same apartment and
not possible to get your hands on a good
Apartment so in Japan most of the
properation management order require you
to have a stable income Sonne
so dauert United
also wenn man ein geregeltes Einkommen
hat sollte es eigentlich gar nicht so
schwer sein eine Wohnung zu bekommen
gerade bei jedem siebte Wohnung in Tokyo
leer steht wenn man sich auf eine
Wohnung bewirbt die irgendwie im
Verhältnis zum Einkommen steht kann man
davon ausgehen sie zu bekommen ist
zumindest das was Eric uns gesagt hat
auf der anderen Seite habe ich mit der
Nippon gesprochen der ist schon krass
fand dass wir diese kleine erste Wohnung
für 700 € angeboten bekommen haben weil
es scheinbar schon Rad ist also das
komplette Gegenteil von dem was ich in
so einer mega Metropol erwartet hätte
und natürlich das komplette Gegenteil
von Deutschland oder Großstädten in
Deutschland ein riesen Danke schön an
Erik der ist uns möglich gemacht hat
diese beiden Wohnung in beliebtesten
Viertel in Tokio anzuschauen wenn ihr
irgendwas in Tokio sucht zum Kaufen zu
mieten alle Kontakte Details sind in der
Videobeschreibung check das aus vielen
Dank fürs anschauen dieses Videos
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
wir sehen uns in den nächsten Tagen
wieder macht es gut ciao
[Musik]